dude I'll tell you this so I got real
high one time and they were playing I'd
never played this game charades have you
played it I've never played it so and so
have you ever played it yeah but have
you done electronically we do it on the
on the thing you hold to your head no
ma'am I'll hold on
oh it's due on 18 no I haven't got out
the [ __ ] board with my family i'm
thanksgiving blade sorry go ahead bro
well i'd never played it dude him it's a
game where someone acts something out
and you guess what's going on yeah and
so I was so high and I sit down and I
start to end and I see what people are
guessing and the guy who was doing the
things was in a wheelchair you know and
he was a handicap that's tough and uh
it's not that tough I don't think you
know I think if you got the [ __ ] in you
know some people now are even on
Gurney's who aren't so worried they used
to be in wheelchairs people yeah I don't
want them on my team though you know I'm
saying oh I don't either the other day
I'm at the Pizza Hut and his family
pushed somebody in her a hamburger
Hamlet and a family pushed somebody in
on the [ __ ] gurney that could have
been in a wheelchair goddamn that's lazy
bro yeah oh I know that Pizza Hut huh
hamburger Hamlet no why did you go to
pizza I love pizza dude on over Domino's
huh the crust bro when I die dude
embalming [ __ ] yourself put cheese in me
bro dude do you wanna be you wanna be
stuff Christ bro imagine you're laying
there in the coffin dude first of all I
want raccoon hands no me too no we're
talking no no dude bro calm down man
this I'm not Brian you know what to just
gave me out of the [ __ ] room everyday
all Brian is is you guys just trying to
like argue that you're not gay until one
of you guys just ends up inside the
other one and it's really a hate crime
even real gay dudes are just like just
[ __ ] each other guys you don't say in
the show is the most flirting I've ever
seen it's five years of Polish means
you're a Pizza Hut guy oh yeah pizza
over Domino's you're [ __ ] crazy
pizza was the only place to go when I
was a kid yeah me too but then I grew up
and realized there's other ones you know
like you ever had you ever had Papa
Murphy's mmm-hmm
where it that's no that sounds like a
guy it's actually on
for the Catholic Church right now I know
papa murphy's that [ __ ] cuz you've
heard of Papa John's right yeah yeah
Papa Murphy's I don't know if they have
them la Ben Denver it's a [ __ ] chain
you buy frozen pizza you get your pizza
not I'm gonna get at home dude so what
really took place I want angry ginger
manager yeah one a couple I want a black
guy who doesn't give a [ __ ] cooking my
pizza
you don't want pizza okay no no it's
about I don't really yeah once that's
time you can you're staying at Pizza
Domino's will bring two pizzas King at
our sting it yeah bro what pizza or
Domino's yeah dude dominoes dominoes is
like somebody took a can full of Pizza
flavoring and sprayed it in a box and
brought it to your house playing [ __ ]
pizza Pete saw his real pizza and his
pizza and the title he thought damn it
was a [ __ ] board game yeah selling
you beats uh-huh that's like hey how
obvious is that what should we call it
well we're in a heart gonna make pizza
yeah [ __ ] stupid at least have pizza
in the title let me finish my story yeah
please do what was it again Chen do you
remember Pizza Hut you're bombing Oh No
and I wanted crazy bread but when you
die I just can't believe that those are
the options burning
first of all cooking somebody that's
good get out of here bro how's that even
an option that's terrifying
I mean it's definitely they're [ __ ]
you on that one
how about this they burn you and then go
we're gonna put your ashes over the San
Francisco bridge yeah [ __ ] and a lot of
dudes are down there on party bar just
catching a mouse yeah smoking myself
didn't [ __ ] you'll be careful underneath
that going Gate Bridge getting that
sharp shower down there
the ashes yeah damn yeah ash is the
haight-ashbury in your face [ __ ] him bro
yeah but that cried him back in you know
so here's what happened to me was uh so
the Pizza Hut oh I've told this story
the first time we almost met an Asian
guy they that almost met an Asian was in
we heard there was a rumor there was an
Asian in town like Janelle who near
nearby 17 miles away okay
so me and two of my buddies cut grass
you know did y'all was on [ __ ] no we
didn't do tiki torches dude this back
when if you were racist she just didn't
tell anybody you just were at the house
you know well so this is a but we were
excited you know we say money me and to
our buddies cut grass to go see this a
rumored Asian okay cuz we never seen
what sure it's exciting oh the only
thing we'd ever seen was American Ninja
Warrior and even that doesn't do it
justice and it's not n it's [ __ ] up if
you think about it's just Van Damme
beating up Asian people never really is
talked true and they're smaller on
camera you don't realize how big there
are they really yeah look at chin yeah
butt chin is uh usually Godzilla of
Korean oh definitely dude he play in
Godzilla he'd play one of the buildings
yes you know or he play like the like
the human giant that [ __ ] sighs so what
happened was we got there we took a taxi
me and two of my buddies to go see this
you know rumored Asian and we get there
knows a pizza it burned down right and
you know pizza other's unique roofs yeah
like a hut yeah yeah cuz they don't yeah
what sells pizza not Domino's oh yeah
Domino's yeah I'll order something from
there that's not in the title Oh where'd
you get this Chinese food Hasbro yeah
yeah Hasbro
what was this uh Milton Bradley [ __ ]
sorry everything has to have the [ __ ]
at least it makes sense of what it is
because so he's so obvious well Little
Caesars I assume I'm like in a [ __ ]
Greek statue delivered to my dude I'm
assuming who's gonna be a young Greek
boy coming over to [ __ ] player you know
what I'm saying nope bro I love it so
different for you so if that delivery
boy gets me to to a couple times that's
all
that'll hold up in court - dude if you
lie named him little season oh if I'm
half an eight ball deep in order Little
Caesars bruh
and he comes with that crazy bread - oh
there better be a small boat with a
mouthful of olives ready to frickin
touch my [ __ ] yeah but anyway so this
this pizza had burnt down and there was
a but that unique roof they had was
sitting flush on the ground and people
thought Asian people lived in it that
makes sense it doesn't make sense now
but at the time I was like I can see how
you guys could you could see how yeah
when it comes to delivery its Domino's
all day
but we can agree on something we might
disagree on that Little Caesars can suck
this dick
well little sigh dog pizza get the [ __ ]
out of my face yeah
and here's a disabled boy look at their
advertisement it's a disabled boy in a
diaper Kenny brain is it's a kid who's
missing a bit of chromosomes and then
yeah look at look at that bro look at
the nose on them that ain't cool
making fun those people yeah it's not
illegal but it's definitely something
that they're trying to you know not have
those inoculations for baby so it
doesn't happen anymore dude here's the
problem - they cut their slices in
squares really squares they don't do
[ __ ] triangles like Americans yeah
squares bro I don't [ __ ] with it yeah
oh wow that huh yep think about it dude
ice work at BJ's pizza dude and they
said it's tough for Black Jacks but it
low-key stood for [ __ ] Pizza oh wow
and it was uh dude it was crazy and at
night we would take the the trash would
get to fold up because everything in
there was straight garbage or the
dumpster out back we got like a mini
dumpster this was at a time in our town
where they tried to save money by giving
people know they're thinking we can have
less pollution if we give people many
dumpsters they won't make as much
garbage right yeah
that's the worst idea ever so then there
was just as much garbage but half of was
laying all around these mini dumpsters
so our thing was we had to get out there
at night at the end of the shift and
burn everything in the dumpster goddamn
so we have to get out there Dave put
gasoline in that paint stain you enough
pain enough for 95 and wound slavery
dude that's as much as an expensive
cookie brush I can bake in here
real gas doubled oozing cookie that's $5
No
yeoreum you'll work for anything dude
and it's obvious by your getup and some
of the [ __ ] you're always peddling on
your Instagram Stewart well what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is that we
would have to get in this dumpster and
just hotbox that thing and just burn all
the trash down to the ground do we be at
work until 3:00 a.m. putting out a fire
in the back making $17
due to my mom sometimes would make me
walk home like we come pick me up she's
like [ __ ] far is it it was honestly not
joking at that time was probably 7 miles
and you run too now yeah and so at that
time I'd run seven you know I'd leave my
apron and everything I work in this run
that hunka seven I run it in pants you
don't run in church pants no oh yeah you
got it
I'll be running Church or painters and
gasoline these are our shoes huh those
Andy Dufresne work shoes all black
no what are those ones that Doc Martens
do low top all the long I'll give you
three guesses what does this mean I
don't know I get in the back all right
you think I'm a kidnapper bro I don't
know what it means dude we used to play
this game me and my buddies we had a
Japanese guy that we met in college and
we would make sounds and see if it was
something most racist thing of the day
no way give him the award for the most
racist thing in the day yeah dull and
even like dude that means look at cloud
cover
that means heavy cloud cover it's so
much Japanese whatever you like nah oh
so there was a fire when I learned play
charades so there was a fire and these
kids are playing the guys in a
wheelchair playing I didn't know how the
game was and so I started guessing I
thought its guest movies that this guy
could be in so I guessed cuz you said I
said silence of the limbs that I
remember you said something earlier cuz
this guy his list some of his limbs
wasn't Isis you know fully functional so
I remember guessing silent to the limbs
I remember guessing Oh Forrest Gump
that's one thing I felt horrible of yes
to cuz I don't know how the game was I
thought they put the guy in the middle I
guess what movies this guy could be in
because people are yelling out you know
dances with Wolfie were yelling out like
Dan you know like I don't remember what
else I yelled out Oh bridge just spina
bifida I remember guessing and that's
the one that [ __ ] met her own
feelings afterwards but I didn't know
you thought of his movies he could be
like yes they're like oh you know what
could Lawrence be in you know and
Lawrence is in a wheelchair you know and
I was like oh these are that's a funny
game yeah think about it your way yeah
yeah like of mice and Massimo it's kind
of hurtful but yeah